[音楽]
ん
wh
voodoo
うん
おっ神こんにちははじめ社長です
yeah
動画のタイトルとサムネイルを見れば分かると思うんだけども
すっ私部屋です
[拍手]
すっても引っ越ししたわけじゃないんですけどね引っ越ししたわけじゃないんですけど
もあのちょっと最近というかこの先ですねどっちかというと
まいます増加に住んでるんですけども多分なんですけどない月からめちゃくちゃ忙しく
なっちゃって
ひょっとしたらじゃなくてもともほぼ確定です孟獲てねー
静岡にほぼ帰れなくなっちゃうわけです僕が静岡に帰れなくなっちゃって
ソースも何で
静岡に帰るかというとやっぱ静岡でしか撮れない動画とか静岡にパソコンもあのデカイ
ですねスペックのパソコンとかもあるし初液剤さてに必要なものとか人でとか将生とか
他の友達とかいろんなものが全部静岡にあるんで僕が動画を撮りたいっつったらも静岡
に帰るしかないんですよ
ところがどっこい by 月ですね8月から実はめちゃくちゃいい人が好きになって
しまっていまして
とりあえずはですとレーザー8月からしばらくの間は東京拠点に活動しようと思って
おりますで7東京2部屋借りてるじゃないですかとかのような言葉ではない部屋借り
てるんですけどもそこもやっぱりな野外やアパートでやっぱり他の人を進んでいるわけ
なんで行っ
タニコーなんか声とか多いとか出しちゃうと迷惑かかったんで正直結構取りづらいとか
あるんですよ
とりでんですけど取れるんですけども取りづらいところがあるんでだいたい片道2時間
かかるんですよ僕ん家から駅まで行って10分へ出る新幹線乗って1時間でそっから
事務所まで移動したりするとだいたい2時間何か買っちゃってを服で余地なんか来る
わけですねそれはもったいないし
東京
の家出る静かにボソボソと動画とってでもこう思ってに行かないしそれで東京で動画
撮りたくなかったんですよ
ってなった時に防犯用の部屋を済みするしかないとそういう理由なんで僕もこの動画は
山でするためだけど
平昌するは youtube のこと何でもするためだけの部屋ゲットしました
トークと落ち着かないねちょっとこの辺はどんな感じなのかちょっと皆さんに紹介
できればいいなと思っております叫び放題暴れ放題
毅放題完全にも僕のための部屋なんで何でもステージ8
投げるのはやめとかまずはゴー品です普段化仏から押さえてるんですけど僕そもそ
暴れる犬のユーチューバーなんで上りたいんですよなんでこの部屋はもう僕がどれだけ
暴れてもいいように
防音機能がば釣りなんです試してみましょう
ん
そうです
させません
日
次行きましょう続いてちょっと部屋の中を見ていきましょう
まあそんなに大きくはないんですけどもず分なサイズがありまーす照明学院このされを
気取る照明敢行してパネルにょ何もないんですけどバトルようにソファーと机と棚だけ
が置いてありますよねこれで暗くできるし
暖色と寒色でね
色が変わるんですよ今たら暖色で殺すと青色に青色青色になる青色これを押すと
ダン速あったかい色サム色あっちゃん朝寒あったかい色っていう感じねやった
もう部屋の照明の間日等も変えられるっていうねもう素晴らしいお部屋になっており
ます
[音楽]
そんぐらいかなはいとき私には見ていったと思うんですけどもいかがだったでしょうか
もうねほんと静岡2台んですよ静岡だと自然も綺麗だし外のさても楽だし
なんせ僕が静岡が好きですなんですけどもまぁちょっとにしばらく本当に東京でマジで
忙しいのでを静岡東京の行き来をしていると動画どころじゃないみたいな
そして持ち
がを節約してもっといない時間はなるべくなくして youtube と度少しでも
たくさん取れるようにずっと頑張って行きたいと思いますので多分まだすぐにはここに
移動しないと思います8月あたりかな8月くらいからここに移動すると思うんで
まあとりあえず東京に来雄平があるよっていう今日はお話でございました
水稼げなくなったら一回静岡に戻ると思うのでそこは安心してくださいちょっと今色々
人
そしていろいろ僕自身も変わろうと思ってるんでちょっとバタバタしていますがまた
またはじめ冊をよろしくお願いしますじゃん
やってないっ
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ